americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 37
and welcome to hannity can you believe
it 37 days americans trapped hostage
behind enemy lines and we want every
single one of our fellow americans home
safely joe biden hardly talks about it
never mentions it maybe he's forgotten
about them we will not forget about them
ever on this show and sadly tonight this
is just one of many serious crises that
joe biden has now caused and is now
unable or unwilling to resolve this
weekend the terrible news just kept
coming and coming and coming first after
weeks about bragging about america's
over the horizon anti-terror
capabilities yeah the biden
administration was finally forced to
admit that last month's drone strike in
kabul yeah it actually killed a
humanitarian worker uh 10 civilians
seven children and zero terrorists and
next after biden promoted covert 19
booster shots for all americans over 16
well his own fda refused to approve that
shot and granting authorization to only
high-risk individuals and people over
65. next up biden brag that america was
once again respected in the world and on
the world stage well france recalled
their ambassador to the us
after getting shafted on a nuclear
submarine deal now this is the first
time in history that france ever
recalled its ambassador to the u.s and
that's not all the administration is
also dealing with accusations of treason
that is leveled at the joint chiefs of
staff that
general milly needs to be put on
administrative leave pending full
investigation sooner than later and then
we move on to biden's border disaster
now a crisis worse than ever seven
months after it started eight months
after he lifted nearly all of president
trump's border protections okay how is
joe biden dealing with the multitude of
crises that he all
he caused every one of them here's what
he had to say over the weekend
mr president does anybody need to be
fired
[Applause]
mr president what will you tell emmanuel
macron mr president
[Music]
[Applause]
nothing he said nothing then went back
to writing on what's that a tricycle i
don't know mountain bike whatever you
want to call it maybe joe your time
would be better spent
maybe getting the americans you
abandoned behind enemy lines now subject
to the terrorists the taliban how about
working on getting them home how about
securing our border how about getting
your message straight on covet looks
like a crisis right now joe we have
nearly under your watch nearly 2 million
illegal immigrants this year alone
you're going to set a 20 25 30 year
record by the way in the middle of a
pandemic and also no testing of all
these illegal immigrants no vaccine
mandates and then they get dispersed all
around the country after they spend time
in your overcrowded
cages with a high rate of covet
positivity and as you can see he was at
the the beach all weekend he answered
zero questions gave zero speeches riding
his little bicycle conducting zero
important meetings there are 12 000 now
as we speak illegal immigrants under
that bridge in texas
and hundreds of americans trapped behind
enemy lines in afghanistan you include
green card holders that's thousands of
americans and covet cases around the
country are surging everywhere and now
he's playing politics with covid and
monoclonal antibodies we'll get into
that later and joe is by the way
spending his long weekend
at the beach doing nothing and according
to circle back jen sake biden while he's
doing his best to protect people
what on his bicycle take a look
if you're talking about the situation on
the ground in del rio one it's a
challenging situation it's devastating
to watch this footage i think it's
important though for people to also know
that what we're trying to do is also
protect uh people
protect people maybe you should have
tested the one and a half plus million
people that came into this country
illegally in the middle of the pandemic
and you should have well had your first
vaccine mandate there and by the way we
have a vaccine mandate for millions of
american citizens
but not for one single illegal immigrant
look at your screen look at the numbers
of people look at the high rate of
covert positivity look at the cages for
kids that joe had been putting people in
there are numero numerous international
travel restrictions for americans but
not at the border not if you're an
illegal immigrant you get special joe
biden treatment over a million and a
half of these migrants from all over the
world pouring across our border
illegally not respecting our laws our
borders our sovereignty and as we speak
thousands are packed together and what
are squalid conditions under the del rio
bridge in texas and according to the ap
some families have been under that
bridge now for more than six days and
get this at least two women have given
birth under the bridge one later tested
positive for coven 19. now when these
illegal immigrants are eventually
processed well many of them will be put
on buses and planes that you pay for and
then dispersed all over the country
tickets paid for by you the american
people no cova testing no vaccine
mandates but you know what jensaki
you're right about one thing these
images they are hard to watch especially
knowing that president trump gifted
president biden with a secure border and
energy independence and three vaccines
and also monoclonal antibodies joe only
mentioned it for the first time last
week but joe biden screwed everything up
he ended trump's stay in mexico policy
stopped the construction on the border
wall he pulled out of reciprocal
immigration enforcement agreements with
neighboring countries and he actually
told migrants come surge the border he
said it well joe they've been surging
now for seven months another 200 000
last month alone no solution this is so
bad that even barack obama that's right
barack obama's department of homeland
security secretary is sounding the alarm
joe are you listening joe this is the
crisis you said isn't a crisis are you
listening
we have to get control of our our
borders
200 000 a month is a lot of people
dhs just released the numbers for august
it's 200 000. august is typically a
month
where it's very low and those kinds of
numbers and the images you just showed
your audience
uh
saps the ability it overwhelms the
ability of dhs the border patrol ice
to cope with uh the the incoming now
don't worry joe's bike riding i'm sure
biden's borders are kamala harris she's
all over it right
seven months into the crisis biden's dhs
secretary did actually visit the border
over the weekend but again we're seven
months too late 1.5 million plus illegal
immigrants into the crisis in the middle
of a pandemic
a little too little too late and they're
still not getting it right